sebastian bau eines gefüllten
kartoffelklöße aus billigen zutaten nach
geschmeckt nach kartoffeln schmecken
frischkäse nur verwendet davon habe ich
wirklich nichts ewig haltbar dank seiner
japanischen spezialmaschine
mit frischkäse und kräutern nicht
gekühlt so aus dem regal
schaue ich mir an
[Musik]
hier ist die füllung
schön gleichmäßig
frischkäse
ja
das machen wir jetzt nach wie unsere
gefüllten mini knödel brauchen wir ganz
schön viele zutaten und na ja sie sind
halt nicht gekühlt deswegen fällt die
frische auch weg
[Musik]
kennen wir alle ins und kartoffelpüree
kartoffeln haben wir schon mal sind auch
nur 14 prozent drin wir brauchen auch
noch mehl reis
[Musik]
mehl
wasser
[Musik]
und noch jede menge zutaten mehr wie
aigner oder sahne pulver alles nur um
einen kartoffelkloß mit möglichst wenig
kartoffel herzustellen
sieht gut aus
das ist schon mal genauso wie
die kartoffelknödel mit gerade mal 14
prozent kartoffeln sind damit fertig als
nächstes stellt sebastian die wundersame
führung her
ein leicht verderbliches milchprodukt
wie frischkäse steckt als füllung in dem
lange haltbaren mini knödel wie macht
man das
suchen sie schon im frischkäse wo bist
du denn frischkäse hallo
frischkäse pulver
das zeugs hier
kein locker minimum ein jahr haltbarkeit
wollen wir die gefüllten mini knödel mit
frischen frischkäse machen
drei stunden haltbarkeit aber mehr auch
nicht
frischkäse pulver ist ein keimfreies
industrieprodukt es ist ewig haltbar und
lässt sich auch zehntel gramm genau
dosieren
[Musik]
wahnsinn oder so schnell macht man eine
frischkäse füllungen mit nur 0,6 prozent
frischkäse
der rest ist gehärtetes fett
kräutermischung gewürze viel zucker salz
modifizierte stärke ein bisschen
milchpulver und da ist die füllung
die bleibt so wir haben dafür kleben
jetzt muss die frischkäse masse mit
gerade mal 0,6 prozent frischkäse nur
noch in den kartoffelknödel kommen
dazu hat sich sebastian lege eine ganz
besondere maschine besorgt die kommt bei
knödel produzenten in der ganzen welt
zum einsatz
das ist mal eine präzisions maschine
eine japanische maschine die
außenmantel
und füllung miteinander kombinieren das
ist ein doppel rohrsystem wo außen die
höhe gemacht wird und das zweite rohr
stecken neben äußerungen rohr drin und
macht dann die füllung und wir haben ein
perfekt gefülltes produkt
jetzt müssen wir die masse erstmal
komprimieren weil umso komprimierte umso
fester das produkt umso weniger
lufteinschlüsse haben wir umso weniger
fläche für mikroorganismen die dann
würde ich vor sich hin wollten und das
ganze produkt verderblich machen
deswegen luft muss raus
den luft enthält sauerstoff und
bakterien in lebensmitteln können die
sich rasant vermehren und essen in
kürzester zeit ungenießbar machen
[Musik]
herrlich wie wer solche maschinen das
macht mir so ein spaß deswegen mache ich
den job
weil man kann mit solchen sachen auch
richtig gute dinge machen indem man
hochwertige rezepturen verarbeitet und
nur die technologie verwendet stück für
stück vereinigt die maschine kloßteig
und füllung ganz ohne teure handarbeit
nur dank cleverer technik lassen sich
solch aufwendige produkte massenhaft zu
billigpreisen herstellen
da sind sie die kleinen freunde ein
wunderwerk der technik so schnell kann
man gefüllte klöße machen
für die zubereitung zu hause muss jetzt
alles für wenige minuten in kochendem
wasser garen
[Musik]
fertig ist der aus kartoffel und
frischkäse pulver zusammengeklebte
kartoffelkloß
wie schmeckt nach kartoffeln schmecken
nach frischkäse nur verwendet davon habe
ich wirklich nicht nur appetit
ohne diese frischen zutaten sind die
produkte ohne kühlung lange haltbar gut
für industrie und handel familie sitzt
auf immer neue varianten der guten alten
kartoffelklöße
und sie müssen ja auch die kultur dieser
unternehmen anschauen die sind eher
darauf ausgerichtet bestehende produkten
technisch weiterzuentwickeln
als ganz neue produkte zu entwickeln
fanny starke doppelt mit dem produkt der
kartoffel um kartoffel ist bei uns auch
wenn es echt ehren der elterngeneration
sehr positiv belegt
seit 1949 sind kann es kartoffelknödel
ein lieb in deutschlands küchen
da kommt ran zu mir gib mir mal wegen so
vsh
felix kennen die die produkte die auf
dem tisch sind ja
ich kenne das alles
die knorr produkte habe ich früher
aufgegessen fanny die kugel hole wundern
das ist ja ganz gut ich habe alles
gefühlt schon mal gekauft hast hier
liegt
seife und mondamin soßenbinder
knorpp astas mac und fannie
bratkartoffeln die marken kennt
praktisch jeder wisst ihr was diese
produkte alle gemeinsam haben ich habe
keine ahnung ich bin sehr überfragt
die wir uns keiner langnese gehört ja
ja das sei
die richtige antwort lautet unilever
unilever und rechts
doch das können verbraucher nur erkennen
wenn sie sich das kleingedruckte auf der
packung ganz genau ansehen
ernsthaft
ja also auch ein imperium
unilever der unbekannte riese
zum konzern gehören wc reiniger von
domestos seifen von do stars ben jerry's
eiscreme und amin hellmanns mayonnaise
und und und mehr als 400 marken sind es
insgesamt in mehr als 190 ländern bietet
unilever seine produkte an knapp die
hälfte seines geschäfts macht der
konzern mit seinem lebensmittel
insgesamt bringt er es auf mehr als 50
milliarden euro umsatz pro jahr
hey und wenn euch unsere videos gefallen
und ihr nicht genug kriegen könnt von
unserem besser ist dann gibt es hier
noch mehr videos und las amazon
abonnieren -button da ich würde mich
freuen bis bald